Hello Everybody! My name Is Markiplier and welcome back to would you rather!
Now I know it's been a while since the last time I did this and I KNOW you guys didn't quite like the quiet version so
you will be very happy to understand that I WILL BE ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS LOUDLY, PROUDLY, and STUPIDLY which is exactly how I live my life!
SO! would you rather always look 8 months pregnant or always have a black eye?
Now I was thinking about this one.. because it all depends on whether or not you are actually pregnant. If I
actually have to live MY life with an 8 month old baby inside me for the rest of my days..
That doesn't seem too comfortable! Because 1.) I don't have a vagina *laughs* and
2.) THATS WEIRD because it's basically a parasite at that point. AND.. always having a black eye doesn't seem too bad.
But if I, if I, if I don't have a baby inside of me (which is a statement I never thought I'd say in my life) but
if I DON'T have a baby inside of me that means I just have a beer belly, a perfectly orb-like beer belly, that.. people love
to come up.. and HUG for some strange reason
BUT if I always have a black eye does that mean someone is always coming up to me and always Punching me in the face at random
*laughing now* points around my life?! Because I'd imagine it'd heal, otherwise I'd just have a black tattoo around my eye.
So... *marki sounds* I kinda gotta go with the black eye because at least I've had a fighting chance- UNLESS it's just
perpetual and less than just a beer belly- But the alternative of having a baby inside you
that's constantly 8 months pregnant... Or having a bat- back- black eye and  someone punching me in the fact repeatedly I guess
i'd go with the face punching. It'd at least make me stronger I suppose.
Would you rather be a nerd or be a jock? Ok THIS is weird because in high school I was kinda splitting the line BETWEEN the two of these.
If I can find that old picture of me, from my teenage years, the DISASTROUS picture that you will see
^ HERE ^
of me, riddled with acne *marki chuckle* Uh, this is just as I started puberty, and when I started puberty,  I got.. REALLY STRONG!
Like, compared to everyone else, I was VERY muscular, and I was VERY athletic! I- I won all the *marki thinking* the Iron Man competition that
we had to teth- test athletithithmmm- if i could even say words properly- SO.. I was both a band nerd AND a jock!
And I WASN'T cool in ANY regard- No matter what: you can be a nerd and you can be cool, or you can be a jock and be cool, but I wasn't EITHER of those!
I was in the middle, and I was still VERY uncool! So I was the least cool muscular nerd you had ever seen in your life.
Sooo I guess I'd go with being a nerd...
Would you rather only speak in questions or only speak in movie quotes?
I don't know if I've answered this one before but only speaking questions would be constantly playing the game that
Whose Line is it Anyways plays, where you have to ask in questions. And I'd be really GOOD at that, but if I was only speaking in movie quotes- I guarantee you
that in every movie ever made is enough to get by, especially considering that I could do other LANGUAGES in other movies.. I could
speak in other lang- OOOOH! I might not know what I'm saying but if I actually know the quotes then I might be able to quote from other languages in other movies
and I GUARANTEE there has been enough- and does this count HOME MOVIES?! Ooh.. I hope it doesn't count specific home movies
and it's just cropping up at random and I just start quoting VERY obscure and risque... amateur home movies
But THAT'S... That's beside the point, but I'm gonna go with speaking only movie quotes because I'm pretty sure I could formulate
something that would allow me to live.
Would you rather Fight Hulk Hogan or Fight Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson?
Well considering that Hulk Hogan is alittle bit older now and Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson Is still in his Prime and VERY STRONG *nervous chuckle*
I've seen him working out.... it's terrifying.
And if I had to fight him... I would DIE. I mean, if I had to fight Hulk Hogan, I'd probably die
If either of these were in a cage match with me, and they wanted to KILL ME DEAD, I would die. HORRIBLY, AND DEADLINESS
But I'll take on Hulk Hogan and hope that he *starts laughing* kind of just falls over from old age!
Would you rather get hit by a bus or watch a loved one get hit by a bus?
THIS ISN'T A QUESTION! Get hit by a bus? I'll take that bus! I'm not gonna let a loved one get hit by a bus for ME!
If you were on a safari, would you rather have your foot stepped on by an elephant or have your foot bitten by a lion?
Ok.. Who's to say that the lion is going to stop when he bites my foot? I mean, if my foot gets stepped on by an elephant, that is pretty much
a GONE foot. *Marki Sounds* It's not a foot anymore, it's a foot pancake. It's just a flat foot, not a foot. You can't use that.
If it get's bitten by a lion It could still be useable. If it's just one bite- but then again you got a Lion on your foot and who's to say
he's not gonna crawl up a little bit north and nab onto something more valuable to me? Sooo... At the RISK of it being
a consistent lion attack and I can't stop him, I'm gonna go with the elephant and sacrifice a foot. Cus then I could get a cyborg leg, and hopefully not die from lion!
Would you rather lick the armpit of a sweaty cab driver or eat the ear wax of an old man who has never cleaned his ears?
UUGH I'M GOING WITH THE CAB DRIVER!! I mean, it can't be THAT bad compared to whatever the hell horror show is in this old man's ears! Eauh!
Would you rather be able to talk to read- WHAT?! Would you rather be able to talk to read minds but you get a really bad headache after you use it OR
be able to fly but you're afraid of heights?
Umm... If I have to THINK like that sentence is in the blue one, then I don't think I WANT that power! Or I could fly and be a fraid of hei- I could conquer my fear of heights!
This isn't that difficult! I could get by! I think- WHY is that 50-50?! *Marki Pause* I mean it's not a crippling fear, it's somethi- I'm a BRAVE MAN well I'm NOT a brave man if anything my horror
playthroughs are anything to say about it, but, you know, I THINK I'D BE OK! I'm just being honest with myself, I think I could conquer that to be able to fly!
I'd rather not have a migraine every time I want to know what grandma's thinking!
Would you rather be dangled over the edge of a cliff or be forced to public speak?
Now this *marki babble* I PUBLIC SPEAK EVERY DAY! I AM MASTER OF PUBLIC SPEAK! ME AM PUBLIC SPEAK REAL GOOD!
ME AM PUBLIC SPEAK TO YOU NOW! YOU AM LISTEN TO ME SPEAK PUBLIC, AND YOU AM SEE WORDS COME OUT MOUTH, AND ME AM NOT CAVEMAN!!!
...
I'll do the public speak...
Would you rather overdose on every drug at the same time or Fall off a 100 story building?
Either one is gonna dead ya, So it doesn't matter what you choose! So I guess... every drug- there's alot of drugs. are we talking only psychadelic drugs because
if this involves every OTHER drug too, maybe the horrible cocktail, because you have both the overdose of the bad drugs and then you have an overdose of the cure drugs, so it's like a
war going on in your body at the same- you'd probably just explode! Like, to be honest, you'd just explode! But maybe you'd have the trip of a lifetime and
I don't think I wanna fall off a 100 story building so I'll take the drugs *Marki Chuckle* I don't know what it's gonna
do to me, if it's every drug- EVERY DRUG!!! EVERY DRUG!!! THAT'S ALOT OF DRUG! THAT'S DEATH BY DRUG!
But it's- it's gonna be a wild ride into the grave!
Would you rather not be able to stop being serious or not be able to stop joking?
That would be... really, really, horrible if you could never stop joking. Like, no one takes you seriously at any point- And I mean living your life
being so serious that you're pretty much Severus Snape going through the world, not enjoying any sort of fun, or joy, or happiness for that matter.
I guess.. I would rather have my point across then always being played for as a fool. So I will take the not stop being serious- WOOOW...
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOUR FUNNY! YOU MIGHT BE JOKING AND NOT BE FUNNY AT ALL!
Would you rather fight a crocodile with a bow or fight an elephant with a shotgun?
OK! So if you shoot an elephant with a shotgun, all you're going to do is piss it off! It's gonna get angrier, and you're going to get deader. That foot stomping that
we were talking about before? Forget all that! It's gonna turn into face stomping, body stomping, and then BALL stomping! NO! Reverse that order!
It's gonna start will ball stomping and then move on up to your face! If I fight a crocodile with a booow, depending one what kind of bow it is and how good it is
and how good my aim is, at least I have a fighting chance! Or I could run away! If an angry elephant is charging after me, I don't
think I'm gonna survive too long, even if I did have a shotgun! I'll take the bow! I wanna go out a BADASS! I wanna be a HERO DAMMIT!!! Actually I'm just killing animals that's horrible...
Would you rather drink a gallon of mustard in one sitting or use mustard as toothepaste for 3 weeks?
There's no reward here! But I mean if you drink a gallon of mustard, could that kill you? I have no idea if you can overdose on mustard!
It wouldn't be pleasant, that's for sure! You can *Marki Sounds* I don't think you can drink a gallon of ANYTHING!!
It's too much fluid in your stomach! So I think you would just EXPLODE in a horrible mustard accident! It'd be a Jackson Pollock painting of mustard.. and blood...
and mucus inside your house! Not good! I'll take the toothpaste! At least i could use normal toothpaste, geez!
Would you rather have a very attractive spouse that treats you badly or have an ugly spouse that adores you?
Well this just depends on how vain you are! But I would never be in a relationship where someone treats me badly, there's no way THAT's happening..
Would you rather, would you rather be chased by 100 rabid squirrels through a flat, open plain or go down a 200 ft slide completely made out of ice head first with your shirt off?
OH MY NIPS! OHOH MY POOR NIPS!! OH GOD NOT MY NIPS!!! I mean if it's 100 rabid squirrels, they are faster then me, so it doesn't
even matter if it's an open plain. I'm pretty sure a squirrel is faster then you. OH BUT MY NIPS!! OH BUT MY TENDER SWEET NIPS!!!
I'LL TA- I'LL RISK THE SQUIRRELS! I'll get a rabies shot afterwards! NOT MY NIPS!
Oh god! Would you rather stop using YouTube or stop using Facebook?
Stop using Facebook! I could NEVER give up YouTube! It's kinda my LIFE!
Aw man! Would you rather always disappoint people or always anger people?
Well this is just that thing that your dad does where he says" I'm not angry, I'm just disappointed." I mean if you're angering people it doesn't mean
that your WRONG but if your disappointing people then, man, that's just sad. I'll go with the angering people.
*Laughs* Would you rather have a conversation with Yoda for 10 minutes or punch Jar Jar Binks for an hour?
Now I'm not a violent man but I have a funny feeling I know what you guys are talking about out there! But if I could
have a conversation with Yoda, I can get alot of wisdom out of that. So I will choose wisdom over the satisfaction of beating up Jar Jar Binks.
I wonder what other people sai- Oh God! There's a surprising number of people who would beat up Jar Jar Binks!
Would you rather bathe in vomit or bathe in wor- *cockatrice mating sounds*
I'll take the worms, but- *Cockatrice reciprocates Mark's call*
OK! So I've got a good question for you guys to leave on that's gonna cause the comments to rage uncontrollably!
Would you rather spend a day with Taylor Swift or spend a day with Beyonce?
I'm not one to into pop culture, so I don't really care either way! I don't have an answer! But I'll let you guys decide down below!
Thank you everybody so much for watching and thank you so much for helping me out and answering these questions and enjoying my stupidity.
So thanks again,
AND AS ALWAYS,
I WILL SEE YOU...
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!!!
BYE-BYE!!!
*Captions done by GoldTheWriter and TwilightFrost18
special thanks to Mr. Markiplier for being awesome and being a hero ;)
I hope these captions helped some of you to be able to experience more of Markiplier :) and enjoy Markimoo's stupidity
Anyways I gotta go actually watch Mark's other videos now!
Have a nice day! CX (Markimoo - senpai notice mee)